the scc is now demanding that more than
250 chinese companies trading in the u.s
markets better inform their investors
about political and regulatory risks
we've seen with things like dd where the
chinese regulators were able to make
very rash decisions and step in and and
make incredible impact where the stock
would fall immediately but those
companies had not disclosed that to u.s
investors and so
chinese adrs
rely on a structure called v-i-e pay
attention get your notebooks out take
some notes here this is going to be free
education v i e is a variable interest
entity we're going to tell you how this
works here
so this specific explanation uses
tencent as an example to explain that
structure of a vie
tencent operates in china under a
restricted list which means that nobody
who is a non-chinese citizen is allowed
to own any equity so if you are not a
chinese citizen you cannot own equity in
tencent according to the chinese
government so as a result 10 cent can't
sell any of its equity to non-chinese
investors
but
it uses a vie structure to circumvent
that so here's how it works tencent the
company in china creates a cayman
islands listed shell company no business
no office no employees which it also
calls tencent and for the simplicity of
this example
let's refer to the actual tencent as
real tencent and the cayman islands
shell company as fake tencent oh god
there is some
truth in every great joke
once fake tencent has been set up in the
cayman islands real tencent then
completes a complex web of legal
agreements that serve to give fake 10
cent a claim on the profits and control
of the assets that belong to real
tencent
now note that there is no recognition of
any actual ownership just a claim on the
profits and an indication of the element
of control
at that point fake tencent now owns as
its only asset these contracts and
agreements fake tencent then lists
itself as a company on the new york
stock exchange selling shares to
investors under the name 10 cent wall
street banks take in millions of dollars
in fees to list fake tencent and
hundreds of investment firms and
investors invest billions of dollars
into buying shares of fake tencent
bear in mind the whole time the western
investors are buying stock in a company
called 10 cent that appears to simply be
the chinese company but fake tencent
appears to have control over the assets
and the right to the profits of the real
tencent in china even though in reality
it's just a shell company with no real
assets or business john where'd you get
this from
uh do you remember no free ads at maybe
zero hedge oh oh of course zero hedge of
course use fake tenseness
so when you think about this ultimately
what's happening with these chinese
companies you're probably hearing a
bunch about the regulators stepping in
and having concerns is one problem that
we have is that we've got the companies
in china no one outside of china or no
non-us chinese or non-chinese citizen is
allowed to own equity so what do they do
they create the shell company they
basically assign some of their value or
some of their profits to the shell
company the shell company is then what
is listed but it has the same name it's
not so clear that it's a shell company
not the real company if a real company
was not on the restricted list and it
listed in the u.s you wouldn't know the
difference unless you went into and
tried to read the actual filing so
there's name confusion the second thing
is that it's a shell company it's not
the real company but investors are
buying it as if it's the real company
the third thing is that there is a big
issue around the accounting treatment so
what you think about accounting is that
in the united states there are
accounting rules that every company has
to follow if you're publicly traded
then you also have to be willing to be
audited and be reviewed by the
regulators so they can come in at any
point say hey show me your books and you
got to show them your books
china historically has said we are not
going to do that there are national
security concerns we are not going to
turn over the books we're not going to
allow you to audit the financials
whoa that's kind of weird uh and so
now all of a sudden the us is saying
maybe we should make sure that we can
audit the financials
maybe we should make sure that we know
whether this is a cayman island shell
company fake tencent or it is a real
chinese company like real tencent that
is actually domiciled in china that
people are buying shares in and then
last but not least is gary ginsler from
the sec and his staff are now
moving towards
requiring chinese companies to actually
disclose any sort of regulatory concerns
that there could be so if you think
there's a chance that the chinese
government can step in and actually
create regulation or use regulatory
rules to impede your business you have
to disclose that to us investors gary
ginsler who has taken the world by storm
as he's become the sec chairman he's got
a new series called office hours and
they create these little videos yes this
video is a right here is paused at or
stopped where gary ginsler is talking
about the cayman islands and saying that
it's sunny and you can go swimming with
the turtles i'm not joking that's
literally what the video says uh-huh and
then he goes on to explain that
going to the cayman islands for the sun
or for turtles is nice
but investing in the shell companies
might not be as safe and fun as
elsewhere so
what do we think in terms of the shell
company let's take that point first
wild that they're using these vie
structures and they're getting away with
actually selling people a shell company
without having to necessarily disclose
or make it obvious that it's a shell
company it's not the real company yeah
well this is kind of similar don't some
of these companies uh like license their
intellectual property to shell
corporations within these tax havens
right so if you're uh you know if we
wanted to license the ip of this show
right and and we created a company in uh
one of these tax havens that he's
talking about i forget which one he
mentioned where all the turtles are
swimming and all this stuff cayman
islands cayman islands if we wanted to
create a company there and we'd license
had a contract with that company from
the best business show and we licensed
all our ip to them and then they don't
get charged taxes on it because it's a
fee isn't this kind of the same thing
well well what you're talking about just
everyone understands is there's a tax uh
loophole of what some companies do is
they have a u.s based company that's
where the headquarters is that's where
the employees are that's where they
build the products that's where they
sell the products what their customers
are for all intents and purposes
us-based company that does business in
the u.s they then create a shell company
in let's say the cayman islands and what
they do is they actually they don't
license they give the iep they sell the
ip to the shell company and the shell
company then license the ip back
and so what the company does is at the
end of the year they look at their us
operations and they say okay cool we
booked a million dollars worth of
revenue we have 500 000 worth of profit
you know what we're gonna do we're going
to create a shell company invoice to the
real company and say you owe us 500 000
for the ip license and then the company
in the us pays 500 000 to the shell
company so now the us-based company
shows zero in profit they pay no taxes
the shell company now got has five
hundred thousand dollars in revenue and
profit there's there's no expenses
associated with this so they have five
hundred thousand dollars in profit but
they are in a tax haven where they pay
no taxes and so it's a way for the
us-based company to pay no taxes and the
cayman islands to actually accumulate
the profits without paying taxes as well
the difference is in that situation you
are actually paying cash to the cayman
islands business but if you were to go
raise capital you would still raise
capital into the us-based you know like
traditional business this is more of
like a tax uh arbitrage yeah what we're
talking about here is the opposite
imagine if instead you went to investors
and you said hey do you want to invest
in my company in the cayman islands and
you pretended like it was the real
company in the u.s yeah that's the and
you can't look at any of the books you
can't do any of these things right
someone made a good comment in the in
the comments here they said uh luck and
coffee was a total scam right remember
that one that was in china where they
were just carson block
you guys know carson block
yeah muddy waters research
legend in the short selling world he he
went to china he cut his teeth
originally he went to china and uh i
forget why he was there something to do
with like supply chains or something and
uh i think his dad was like a stock
trader if i remember the story correctly
and his dad was like hey can you go
check out this business for me and he
went over there and was like
what business
like that like there was like nothing
there's just a building right he was a
different company yeah this is i think
oriental paper is how he got started and
uh he like wrote a report and he like
sent it to his dad and was like uh
there's no business here maybe he like
sent it to investors like he did he
basically figured it out and he like
wrote it and published it and uh and
they shorted it and the stock went down
like 90 percent like that he nailed it
and so it then became he started to
build his reputation as a short seller
of uh when carson block comes after you
be careful like you're likely not to
he's got boots on the ground somewhere
well he's gonna take it into it he's got
boots on the ground but like also
there's a um i forget the uh
the documentary i think it's called
china hustle is that what it's called
the china hustle is a 2017 finance
documentary produced by magnolia
pictures uh
that basically looks at all of this
before we got to this point this is five
years ago right four years ago and
carson block is one of the main
characters in that documentary it's an
absolute awesome documentary and it go
and like they have like footage they're
like by the way these people say that
they're doing a hundred million dollars
in uh monthly revenue here is a video of
their loading dock and they just like
have like they set up like across the
street in an office building they just
video the loading dock and there's like
one it's like out of a movie the guy's
like walking into work whistling like
twisting his keys in his hand and no
trucks show up the whole day yeah right
and they're like what do you mean
there's there's nothing coming in or out
of this facility so i think that's where
uh people started to uh uh really got to
okay people are now saying has carson
heard about and they're listing [ __ ]
coins
uh john what do you think you said you
were the one who found this this is
super interesting to me i didn't i did
not know about this to be honest i
didn't know that if you're buying shares
of alibaba on a us-based exchange you're
not actually owning the shares within
the like real company in this case
alibaba right so alibaba uh tencent dd
all these companies that are
chinese-based companies uh it's super
interesting how they get around this i
like the fact that the u.s is imposing
these laws in the sense of hey look you
have to open up your books we want to
make sure there's nothing going on you
have to inform investors about potential
regulatory risks and all that that goes
around it um yeah and going forward i
can see them getting removed if they
don't do that
do we think that the us should punish
the companies that are already here or
do we think the u.s should basically say
anyone coming forward you have to follow
they stopped they stopped allowing the
chinese companies to do ipos already so
they they already paused new companies
from coming here but what should they do
with the companies that are here
they should give them a deadline to
start opening their books they did not
saying it didn't three years i think
that's correct yeah uh i think that's
one piece the second piece is if they
don't comply then they should kick them
out yeah exactly if you don't meet this
deadline then you're gone like we got to
get more ruthless in the world yeah what
you're saying don't trust verify don't
trust verify show me the numbers show me
the numbers i just showed you that the
whales are bringing bitcoin onto the
exchanges i can show you in near real
time these people are over here they
won't even let you look at it national
security yeah
guess what national security the u.s
should say national security get out
just kick them out hey guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today and don't forget to
check out our partner sofi they make all
this possible they're a super app that
lets you save spend borrow earn and
invest all from one single platform and
if you go there today and you sign up
for a sofi invest account you can get
between five dollars and a thousand
bucks for free from sofa not everyone's
obviously gonna get a thousand dollars
but everyone gets something don't say
that i never did anything for you go
check them out at sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]